foreign
to Tech news briefing it's Thursday June
8th I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street
Journal
investigations by The Wall Street
Journal and researchers at Stanford
University and the University of
Massachusetts Amherst have found that
Instagram helps connect and promote a
vast network of accounts openly devoted
to the commission and purchase of
underage sex content these pedophilic
accounts are Brazen about their interest
using hashtags like pedohar and pre-teen
sex to search for sellers of child sex
material
and seller accounts often claim to be
run by children themselves and use
overtly sexual handles both of these
things violate policies of Instagram's
parent meta the company has acknowledged
the problems with its enforcement
operations and vowed to improve them
with me to discuss this is our social
media reporter Jeff Horowitz who covered
these investigations with reporter
Catherine blunt and Jeff when someone on
Instagram searches for one of these
pedophilic hashtags what kind of
material are they finding so a network
of accounts that is very openly
advertising child sexual abuse material
for sale a lot of it is self-generated
but basically kids and teenagers that
are essentially offering really vile
stuff up into including self-harm and
bestiality content these hashtags are
kind of watering holes for a community
to form a round that is interested in
this stuff the investigations found that
Instagram helps connect and promote
these kinds of accounts how did
researchers find that the platform is
doing that so recommendation systems are
very good at connecting people to the
communities that they want to be part in
and the content that they're interested
in and it's no different for pedophiles
so obviously there's a lot of pedophiles
on Instagram because Instagram has 1.3
billion users or a little more than that
the question is how does the platform
treat them and the answer is that it
caters to their interests by basically
suggesting at every turn content that
might be interesting to them so that
could be video videos of little girls
dancing that could be if they enter a
hashtag that is a little creepy it might
suggest another version of it that has
say an indication that it is going to be
specifically devoted to child
pornography it might be suggesting that
they look at similar pages to or similar
accounts to one that is purporting to
sell underage sex content yeah can you
explain a bit more about how that works
if you're not specifically searching for
this material how might you end up
coming across it so I spoke with a woman
named Sarah Adams She Goes by the handle
mom dot uncharted on most social media
she is a Canadian parenting related
activist her main focus is the idea that
pretty much devoting social media
content to your children is a form of
exploitation and of itself and she you
know in the course of doing sort of
online activism gets sent terrible
things all the time from people who are
like can you believe this and one of
those accounts was and I'm sorry to have
to use these words or named incest
Toddlers and it was a meme account of
pro pedophilia memes she reported it to
Instagram didn't think anything more
about it just took a few seconds to just
like click a few buttons and basically
say what what's going on this is
terrible take it down and over the next
few days her followers started
bombarding her with questions saying
like what what is going on I'm when I
look at your profile I'm being being
told to check out incest toddlers And
this is actually the algorithm working
exactly as it is intended to do which is
that the people who are interested in
incest toddlers the pro pedophilia meme
page are very strongly interested to it
right that's a niche Community with a
obviously serving a particular audience
but yeah I would say that if you are
really uninterested in this stuff it's
not like Instagram's going to shove it
in your face I think that the question
isn't whether Instagram is trying to
push everyone toward pedophilia so much
as whether the platform is facilitating
the formation of a community that
normalizes and facilitates the grooming
and abuse of children the promotion of
underage sex content violates
Instagram's rules as well as federal law
so what has meta the parent company of
Instagram said about the findings in
these investigations so in response to
what we and Stanford and UMass have all
been talking to the company about they
have removed thousands of hashtags
they've moved large numbers of posts
they're planning future actions they
have set up a child safety task force
internally and they have discovered some
operational failures so one thing that
was happening is that a glitch sort of a
software glitch was causing them to
discard many user reports of child
sexual abuse without reviewing them and
they have found that and fixed it that's
what the company says they have also
given their moderators new training
suggesting that maybe they should be a
little bit more proactive in taking down
this stuff is I think the takeaway
they've also said they are working on
preventing their recommendation systems
from recommending that suspicious AKA
potentially pedophilic accounts don't
get recommended to each other and aren't
allowed to follow each other Jeff the
laws around child sex content are
extremely broad investigating even the
open promotion of it on a public
platform is legally sensitive what did
University investigators say about the
findings so the university researchers I
think were all very surprised that this
was this bad I think everyone kind of
generally understands that these are you
know chronic problems but the the thing
that I think came as a shock to everyone
was uh you know that this has been
allowed to sort of fester and grow to
the scale it has I think there was an
expectation that a company such as meta
with the resources that it does and the
need to make sure that their platform is
safe for advertisers and kids that they
wouldn't have done a better job without
prompting so what did the researchers
say about fixing the scale of this
problem so I think that the thing that
Stanford and UMass have been very
focused focused on is that Instagram
needs to one block the discovery
mechanisms that are leading people to
these communities and to just like
invest heavily in human research to
track what's happening how how does the
problem on Instagram compare to other
social media platforms this is difficult
to say Stanford focused on this network
sort of open child sex content sellers
you know and those they operate across
platforms they have links to Snapchat to
Twitter and so forth but like really the
center of it was Instagram I think a lot
of that comes down to just sort of
platform features to some degree
Instagram makes it so easy to see who's
following who and recommends so many
different things and recommends
connections not just content that it's
sort of a higher risk place that was our
reporter Jeff Horowitz thanks for
joining us Jeff happy dude
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing for more Tech stories head over
to our website wsj.com
I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street
Journal thanks for listening
[Music]